welcome to this video we call kar 1985
Nikita on my you're off right and plate
it before a couple of times I don't
really remember what that was if we play
this Chuck people tend to know what the
good lines by now there's one of the
best lines that white can play against
this opening queen bee tuna oops sorry
it was a bottle here near me and it just
popped somehow ok so v6 should be seven
wyd is slightly better him Bentham and
blacks position is still really solid so
94
you can also go back to the seven so
that's a bit the bit of a passive move
our Creator I can go to creative our
blacks pollution is some pretty hambone
yes I mean all my pieces are doing
something he still has the bishop pair
of it not so clear what it is doing at
the moment is it very dangerous okay
take some control over you for here
interesting
cannot go 94 now
so let's see hmmm beat so bad but what
am i doing exactly before I always have
that 94 a for resource can maybe make my
night a little bit more flexible that
was the idea ok I didn't think about
that at all so you want to take you five
let's have another not sure maybe this
one taking a three maybe you can just go
back to be too high yeah that's possible
and rope the eight ok so let's do this
trade maybe my position is somewhat
unstable now I'm not sure about that
all those pieces they look kind of kind
of shaky a little bit I should back
there yeah I think I have to get the
Queen back night h4 may be coming and
this is hanging on b6 maybe this is a
good move I don't know covering b6 and
lending additional support to f6 night
h4 I have 92 okay that's important maybe
this is the reason for for this move
then yeah may I put puppet put this this
out first he goes back okay maybe 94 is
something that is in the air okay I'm
putting the Queen back really not sure
what it is doing 183 anymore maybe 94s
even a move sometimes
damn difficult piece play here 94 that's
probably not g4 so that's not dangerous
I believe not sure what I'm doing if he
is playing some kind of slow move really
snide c5 something that I really thought
that would be player why is that
playable don't get it okay so show me I
didn't see that one okay night I can't
even take only 3 here and then 96 SS did
move rope cheese room 26 root g 60 is is
possible night a fire forever Jesus
wondering what a position
I can I'm doing this what happens here
night f5 do I have something against
this yeah maybe maybe just Queen g6 yeah
Quincy six or something wow what an
utter total mess
is that a huge problem I don't know I 97
at the end of that time worrying what is
to protect occur that was certainly
noise I don't think that had any problem
check check I think I rather was better
but I don't know yeah yeah I fail to see
that tactic
okay so let's black resigns hmm yeah
complicated them well maybe I should
have reconsidered that NYCHA phone with
a little bit I mean he didn't overlook
at so I mean at least I hope I he didn't
so young computer gives night takes III
being okay yeah so the idea but I didn't
really see anything great after that
kate wants me to take their what a total
mess the valuation is of course 000
Quincy to rookie six Jeffrey check this
is the the drawing line check of the
engine I am I came so well I went here
night at five and now yeah this losses
due to exactly the game I didn't see the
97 check at the end this is what the
engine wants me to play and gives why
the slight edge after Queen be 26
check where this is a slight edge I
don't understand anything here shy what
is a piece of Isis just 0.6 mi winning
so many paws down okay if i get that i
see that i have drawing chances yeah
pretty realistic one to us well they're
very difficult stuff okay well thanks
for watching